the mother accused of killing her
seven-year-old son and leaving his body
in an area near mountain springs admits
to killing him
thirty-five-year-old samantha moreno
rodriguez making her first
court appearance here in las vegas she
told police
she choked her son liam houstead our big
alcoholman live in the newsroom with
what we learned in court today bianca
samantha moreno rodriguez was extradited
here from denver earlier this week
her court appearance today was a warrant
return hearing she faces one count of
murder in the death
of her son now according to liam
houston's family and police reports he
was autistic
back in may moreno rodriguez left her
home in san jose california with liam
and they made a stop here in las vegas
in court the prosecution shared moreno
rodriguez became frustrated with lamb
strangling him for about 15 minutes
she then took his clothes off and left
him in a hiking area near mountain
springs
after she drove to denver there police
tracked her down
the judge today did not grant bail
the choking strangling the child
disposing of the body after
he was deceased and then going to
colorado
i do find that that burden was met now
if that we have the preliminary hearing
and there's an issue with that
confession this
will be redressed okay i will always
leave that door open for you
but for right now the state did make its
burden i'm granting the state's request
she is remanded without bail when the
boy was found it took some time for him
to be identified a friend of the family
saw reports contacting san jose police
department
and liam's dead also during this
morning's court proceedings mourinho
rodriguez was assigned a public defender
she's expected to be back in court
august 3. bianca holman 8 news now